niemand passt mehr rein plötzlich
herrscht am Morgen Chaos an den
S-Bahnhöfen in Hamburg Schneefall hatte
eingesetzt einige S-Bahnlinien daraufhin
komplett eingestellt andere kommen eher
nur noch zufällig und sind dann
hoffnungslos überlastet viele Pendler
erst überrascht dann genervt bisschen
Schnee und nichts geht mehr ne schlimm
also ich ich komm heute zu
spät und warte die drei Bahnen noch mal
ab weil das ist viel zu voll das hält
man ja nicht aufesag chaotisch ist
komm mal zwei Flocken Schnee bricht
alles zusammen die Folgen für Reisende
warten auf die nächste Bahn die
wiederbrechend voll ist dabei kommt der
Winterdienst draußen vor den Bahnhöfen
tatsächlich dank Dauereinsatzes noch
ganz gut zu Rande völlig anders als im
Süden Deutschlands etwa hier am
Flughafen München auch hier fahren am
Morgen zwar ununterbrochen Räumfahrzeuge
über Start und Landebahn alles was
verfügbar ist kämpft gegen Schnee und
Eis an und doch müssen alle Flugzeuge
stehen bleiben im Terminal wenig
Passagiere bei denen die doch gekommen
sind herrscht
Ratlosigkeit aufgrund der aktuellen
Wetterlage ist der Flughafen München bis
12 Uhr geschlossen der grund für die
Sperrung gut sichtbar vor dem Flughafen
Eisregen hat über Nacht die kalten
Straßen und Gehwege in Rutschflächen
verwandelt die Stimmungslage bei den
Passagieren irgendwas zwischen
schicksalsergeben und
sauer irgendwie heimkommen keine Ahnung
noch wie ach ich bin da eigentlich noch
positiv keiner kann was für die
Situation erst in diesen Minuten soll
der Flugverkehr wieder aufgenommen
werden die Winterdienste sie werden noch
den ganzen Tag nonstop die Flächen
freihalten immerhin gibt es genug in
München anders als etwa im Saarland auch
hier sorgen Eis und Schnee für heftige
Probleme doch zeitgleich gibt es seit
gestern schon einen Warnstreik im
öffentlichen Dienst es kommt zur
Einschränkung bei der straßenräumung und
so bleiben immer wieder LKW auf den
Eisflächen liegen blockieren hier etwa
die
A1 nichts zu machen erst recht nicht
wenn dann noch das richtige Equipment
fehlt
l ich bin hier seit zwei Stunden und ich
komme einfach nicht mehr weg ich bleib
jetzt hier und
warte in Brandenburg fließt der Verkehr
zwar aber die vermeintliche Entspannung
ist trügerisch das Problem für
bundesweit alle Autofahrer gefrorener
Schnee auf fahrzeugdächern BGT große
Gefahr der Fahrer dieses PKW etwa hatte
Riesenglück bei Brück auf der A9 wurde
sein Fahrzeug von Eisplatten eines
vorausfahrenden Fahrzeugs
getroffen die sind dann auf einem
nachfahrenden PKW gelandet der Pkw kam
im weiteren Verlauf dann auch von der
farbn ab und kollidierte mit
warenbaken der Autofahrer erlitt leichte
Verletzungen bei dem Unfall und wurde
vom Rettungsdienst zur weiteren
Behandlung in ein Krankenhaus gebracht
die Polizei redt deshalb weiter im
ganzen Bundesgebiet besonders Abstand
halten und das noch bis mindestens
Donnerstag erst dann soll es deutlich
wärmer werden und die Schnee und Eislage
könnte sich spürbar
entspannen